hello everybody and welcome to the
eleventh practical flask tutorial video
in this video we're going to be talking
about user logins now this is actually a
pretty large topic it would take a
really long video to do it in once it's
going to be quite a few videos or at
least a handful of them because the
topic is pretty large so we have to in
the in the topic of user logins you have
quite a few you know subtopics so you've
got forms so HTML forms submitting forms
so now we're going to be talking about
posting data to the server then we've
got you know grabbing that post data so
getting the data that was posted we've
got that then we've got the this notion
of usernames and passwords so we're
taking a username and password we need
to store them somewhere so now we've got
to incorporate databases and because
it's a username in the password which is
kind of sensitive information now we've
got to talk about encryption so it's
obviously a pretty big issue and then
not only that after all of that we also
have to talk about injections so because
we're using a database we have to talk
about sequel injection and other things
that people might use to either hack
into your website and do something you
know steal some user information or to
be just malicious and commit some
vandalism against your website as well
through SQL injection so anyways it's a
huge topic so let's go ahead and dive
into it so here's our website at the
moment we were just testing these
flashes and all that everything's
looking good up to this point now on the
actual home page we have this pop-up
login screen and that's fine well we'll
be using that in a little bit and then
also the signup screen as well and
you'll notice that this form is a little
different than this form and there's a
reason for that I'm going to show you
there's you know many ways to create
forms and validate forms and all of this
and so I'm going to show you both ways
using this I just so happened to test
both ways myself and then I left it I
don't feel like changing it I do like
this method better except the form the
actual forms look more attractive
because I'm using the bootstrap code as
opposed to
these forms here but you can incorporate
the bootstrap code around these as well
so anyway moving along we're not going
to touch these yet so we're going to
talk about just the login page now there
actually is no login page at the moments
for turning it's interesting gave me an
internal server error rather than the
404 anyway this is what it is there the
404s and the page just doesn't actually
exist yet so that's what we're going to
do now is we're going to build this
login page
so coming over here first we're going to
go ahead and need a login template now
our most basic template actually is
either the 500 error or the 404 error so
we're just going to duplicate that
template so we're going to duplicate
come over here and we're going to rename
it login HTML that's fine you may have
to enter your password again and then
now you should have a login dot HTML
here so we'll bring that up and this is
our login dot HTML let me scroll it in a
little bit and so now it's a 404 page
but now we can convert it to any other
pages that we want just by doing this
awesome now it's a login page okay so
now we have to actually build this login
page so because it extends header h2 ml
and in fact I think our 400 error is a
oh no we do a block body okay
I guess I just deleted it by accident
we'll leave the block body stuff there
okay so now it's a login page but it has
nothing there the other thing that we
need to do is we need to go back to our
init dot pi file open that up let me
make the font a little bigger real quick
and what we want to do here is actually
add the page itself so we can basically
copy any page that already exists we'll
take the home page copy that come down
here paste instead of just slash its
slash login slash change the function to
be login page and then the template we
want to render is login dot HTML so now
what we want to do is we'll save that
from now we're not going to really mess
with anything actually we're going to
add one more thing real quick to this
page and that's going to be methods so
methods equal and then it's a list and
we're gonna have two things in this list
you've got get and post okay so get and
post our requests so if you recall for
maybe URL Lib two for example URL Lib
were in Python three now uh-huh
if you recall from that you might do a
get request so that's getting stuff from
the server you might do a post request
that's putting stuff on the server now
I'm not a web development expert by any
means but I've been in web development
for a decent amount of time I've been
dealing with requests for a decent
amount of time and up until only very
recently I've learned there's actually
another form of a request and it's a
delete request every web site API that
I've ever used uses either get or post
you post a delete query or a delete
command or whatever but there's actually
a delete method or a delete request
method I had no idea that that existed
but it's a real thing interesting
maybe someone else's mind is blown
anyway I was reading a API information
for a Bitcoin exchange and they used a
delete method I was like where's the
information on delete and I was like oh
that's actual request method it's
incredible anyway no one ever talks
about it so login methods get post cool
so you have to add methods get post
because naturally by default flask does
not allow get and post so for example if
we are to go to our dashboard page on
our website and let's add a quick
request so you've got to add like a post
for example you can use the question
mark symbol and you do the question mark
at a variable so we'll just say variable
variable equals this enter and it's
actually not going to do anything
because we're not asking for it but then
you could also say and another equals
another okay these are posts but I guess
it's just letting it pass through just
simply because we're not actually doing
anything with them but in a second
you'll see at least with the submit that
you actually really can't it's going to
yell at you anyway
that's basically how you would do a get
or a post via the link or by the URL but
anyway we're going to do it via forum so
you have to add in methods get in post
otherwise it won't do it get in post is
it's not it's not like it's a security
risk but it is one more hole so to speak
so it's kind of like ports right when
you have open ports the more you know
open ports you have they're just open
ports they might be secured but they
might not be there might be other issues
so if you have a website and there's no
get in post it's a lot harder for
someone to get into a website as opposed
to a website that allows get in post
it'll be a little easier but it has
really less to do with get in post and
more to do with how you handle the get
in post but anyway by default there will
be no get in post so you have to add
that in and I'll show you the error
later if I remember to what happens when
you don't have get in post so we're
going to come back over to our HTML page
and we're going to build the form I
think we're all done with the login page
though so we'll close that come over
here and let's do a quick service Apache
to restart and that should be the last
restart that we have to actually issue
here we are let's refresh real quick and
then now let's click on login sure know
if we have the the page there is nothing
there but we have it so now we are going
to open up this and fill in our body now
so within our actual body what we're
going to do is we're going to add a body
tag and then we're going to fill in a
quick form so we're going to put in a
div tag so we're going to have books div
class equals and this is going to be a
container div so that's a bootstrap code
/ div div czar not bootstrap just for
the record there just div tags that's
used all over the place but the class
equals container
the container part is what is a more
bootstrap and then you got container
fluid as well that you'll see us use
both of moving right along we're going
to add a quick break so we've got some
space between this in the top then we're
going to have some header for texts
whoops and this is just going to say
please login : and then once we have
that we're going to add one more break
and then we will begin our form so we've
got form form as Python folk you're
probably having a hard time with all the
spaces but are the you know tabbing
stuff over so let's go ahead and make
ours a little more better so let's have
that over so you know this block of code
is contained within this div here and
rather this block of code and then stuff
in the form will be tabbed over as well
but first form it's not we don't really
neat we'll just have action equals
nothing for now class equals a form -
inline and then the method of this form
is gonna be post okay so the reason why
the variables in the URL didn't really
do anything it didn't yell at us is
because we didn't actually specify the
method so it basically it's not going to
throw an error but now we've explicitly
said hey we want this to post so when we
hit submit button it's going to run a
post request and that's going to fail
because we didn't allow it or well now
we're allowing it but I'll show you what
will happen when we're not allowing it
so that's our form form cool method post
that's fine now we need to add some
input so we've got input and then we've
got type and the type of input here
zoomy text so this is going to be where
the user is allowed to enter their
username so text we've got class here is
going to be form control and then the
place holder this is stuff that's like
within
the like the box previous to when
someone actually types placeholder will
be equal to username let me do this here
this over cool
okay placeholder will be username the
name of this field this is basically how
you can reference this field the name of
the field will literally be username and
then the value of this field is going to
be a variable for now but that variable
is going to be request dot form dot
username so this is a be our way of kind
of passing this data back to Python and
that's it for this now we're going to
basically do the exact same thing again
only this time it's going to be a
password so we'll take this form here
copy that
come down here paste place hold let's
see text input type this input type
needs to be password because it we want
it to make little stars instead of the
actual text as people type it in
placeholder will be let's capitalize
password and let's go ahead and
capitalize username from above as well
password the name here is password and
then the variable that we're going to
assign this to is going to be just
request form dot password okay then
finally so those are the fields now we
need the submit button so we have one
more input and that's going to be class
equals and this is going to be some
bootstrap code here so class BTN space
BTN - default that's for the default
button of bootstrap the type so what is
this button it's a submit button and
then value this is what is the button
actually say and that's going to be
actually we'll call it login and that's
it that's our the end of our form so we
can save that form now and I guess I
didn't really see it update but I'm sure
did refresh sure enough there is our
form please
login username password we can type in
our username as Harrison and then we
could say our password is hi there like
that we can hit login it did do
something you saw it load hopefully we
can do it again it's doing stuff but
that we're not actually handling
anything it is submitting data but it's
not being handled now as promised let us
show you or less we've closed it already
what would happen instead though if we
come down and we did not allow these
methods so what if we just had login
let's whoops I mean to click on that
click on I like all the time
refresh its restarted now we click login
and you get this method not allowed so
you may or may not want to have an error
page that handles this method not
allowed air as well but we'll worry
about that later and just for the record
that's a 405 so you can make a pretty
thing like error handler you might be
able to even get away with this let's
try it and it's gonna handle the 405
page not found I will just say this is
method method not found save refresh
that fresh the login will resubmit the
data yeah cool so if you wanted to
handle it that's how you could handle it
and in fact I hate to leave it like a
mess like this so we'll just throw in
405 there save that so we're going to
come over to our templates let us
duplicate 404 make that 405 dot HTML
edit this
that method let's do that request method
is not permitted on this page something
like that cool we'll come over here
restart that come on over to this and
then confirm for me submission yeah and
then we get yeah that request method is
not permitted on this page so that's a
little a better way to handle that error
anyways okay so we've got our form at
least let's go back to that form we've
got a form here we've got some
information we are able to actually let
me go ahead let's add back those methods
before I forget methods equals get
actually needs to be get post sit book
save that fresh let's just make sure
before we leave this one that we did
this right so we've got a form got our
passwords we can enter but we're not
actually handling them so we've got what
we need to at least get started with but
now we've got to handle the actual get
in post do maybe some simple validation
by a no database let's say just allow
the user login somehow so I can show you
how we're will use the information
that's input via flask and how we're
actually passing that information back
let's probably what we'll do in the next
video then pretty quickly we're actually
gonna have to cover registration first
because I don't really see much point in
going too much further in the login
because eventually we have to actually
validate the login credentials against
the database of usernames and passwords
to get a database of usernames and
passwords we kind need a registration so
we can set that up and then we'll come
back to actually validating a login so
lots of stuff to cover with logins it's
a confusing confusing topic lots of
people get it wrong and times change so
anyway it's a it's a challenging topic
but it's an interesting topic at the
same time so anyways stay tuned for that
we'll be covering more on dealing with
getting post requests then registration
and all that validation corruption and
all that fun stuff so stay tuned for
those if you guys have any questions or
comments on this video please feel free
to leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching
things for all the sports subscriptions
and until next time